hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir blicken
heute auf die ukrainischen Angriffe auf
die Krim das ist die völkerrechtswidrig
annektierte Halbinsel und die gilt ja
als einer der wichtigsten russischen
Militärstützpunkte wir haben über diese
Halbinsel lieber ZDF heute live immer
wieder gesprochen und in den letzten
Tagen konnte ich hier auf der russischen
Armee dort mehrere empfindliche Schläge
setzen lasst uns mal auf die Bilder
gucken zu Beginn der Woche nahmen
ukrainische Truppen zunächst mehrere
ölbohrtürme im Schwarzen Meer ein dieser
2015 besetzt waren und von denen das
russische Militär den Schiffsverkehr mit
Radaranlagen überwachte am Mittwoch dann
der Angriff mit Marschflugkörpern auf
einen trocken doch in Sebastian
russisches U-Boot und ein Landungsschiff
schwer beschädigt worden sind bei einem
Drohnenangriff auf der Krim soll
außerdem ein Flug Abwehrsystem zerstört
worden sein
ja und wir fragen uns deshalb heute
welche Strategie steckt hinter diesen
ukrainischen Angriffen und ihr sitzt
schon hinter mir wackelt jetzt Putins
Festung also die Halbinsel Krim und wie
immer bespreche ich das mit Gästen die
ich mir eingeladen habe zum einen mit
militäranalyst Franz Stefan Gady und mit
ZDF Reporter Heiner Hebestreit der uns
live aus saporisha zugeschaltet ist und
wie immer auch mit euch wenn ihr Fragen
an die Gäste habt oder eure Meinung zum
Thema mit uns teilen wollt dann tut das
sehr sehr gerne entweder direkt hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an die
Mailadresse dir unten eingeblendet seht
und jetzt stelle ich euch erstmal
unseren heutigen Gast vor
Franz Stefan Gady ist unabhängiger
militäranalyst er war dafür in den
vergangenen Monaten auch immer wieder an
der Front in der Ukraine zuletzt im Juli
Gady arbeitet unter anderem für das
Center von New American Security und das
international Institute
studies in London er berät Regierung und
Streitkräfte in Europa und den
Vereinigten Staaten
ja und jetzt ist er uns live
zugeschaltet schönen guten Abend
guten Abend
die ukrainischen Angriffe auf die Krim
sorgen derzeit für Erfolgsmeldung in der
Ukraine lassen sie uns da direkt mal
einen Blick auf die Karte werfen da
sehen wir es mehrere ölbohrtürme im
Schwarzen Meer wurden eingenommen wir
sehen hier die beiden Städte auf die ist
Angriffe gab und dort wurden ein U-Boot
ein Landungsschiff und ein
Luftabwehrsystem getroffen wie schätzen
sie denn diese ukrainischen Angriffe
eins und das vereinzelte Aktion die wir
jetzt hier sehen oder ist das doch
größerer Teil einer neuen Strategie
also ich glaube nicht dass es eine neue
Strategie ist es ist Teil einer
sogenannten abnutzungsstrategie die sehr
gut in der Vergangenheit für die Ukraine
gearbeitet hat
abnutzungsstrategie heißt dass sich dem
Gegner Versuche disproportional größere
Verluste an Menschenmaterial zuzufügen
als ich selber erleide und in dieser
Hinsicht ist das ein Teilstück von
dieser abnutzungsstrategie die
eigentliche größere Abnutzung findet
selbstverständlich direkt an der Front
statt direkt an den russischen
Verteidigungslinien eben in saborischer
im Süden von der Netz und so weiter aber
natürlich steckt dahinter die Idee dass
wenn er eben konzentriert Kommando
Bunker
Munitionsdepots Verkehrsknotenpunkte
andere strategisch wichtige
Infrastrukturen zerstört im Hinterland
der Frontlinie man dadurch eben die
Truppen an der Front auch schwächt und
das sehen wir eben also die große Frage
für mich ist inwiefern diese ganzen
Einsätze Teil einer eines systematischen
Ansatzes sind oder eben wirklich nur
jetzt punktuell in den letzten Tagen
stattgefunden haben
ja sie haben es gerade schon gesagt Teil
dieser abnutzungsstrategie ist ja auch
den Gegner militärisch zu schwächen
ihnen sein Gerät abnutzen zu lassen
jetzt ist die Krim einer der russischen
Militärstützpunkte inwiefern haben denn
diese Aktion die wir jetzt gerade
gesehen haben Russland schon logistisch
und militärisch beeinträchtigt
das ist eben die große Frage und hier
muss man offen sagen dass die Datenlage
hier nur dürftig ist ich glaube
grundsätzlich haben wir keine größere
Minimierung zum Beispiel der russischen
artillerie-rate artillerieschutzrate
gesehen in den letzten Tagen also die
Russen haben noch genügend Munition an
der Frontlinie selbst es gibt also
genügend Nachschub in daraus muss ich
schließen dass der Nachschub nicht
derartig beeinträchtigt ist eben dass es
hier zur Reduzierung der russischen
Kampfkraft kommt das bedeutet aber nicht
dass diese Angriffe nicht längerfristig
vielleicht einen Einfluss haben werden
oder auch wie gesagt punktuell im
Einzelnen von Sektoren im geschwächt
haben also hier ist wirklich muss man
sagen der Nebel des Krieges noch sehr
stark und hier müssen wir auch abwarten
wie sich die Situation entwickelt
was wir aber mit ziemlicher Sicherheit
ja wissen ist dass die Ukraine aktuell
ziemlich viele Marschflugkörper einsetzt
wie ist es denn mittlerweile um die
Reserven der Ukraine bestellt
nun die genauen Zahlen hier
kenne ich nicht aber man kann
da man mal be vielleicht rechnen dass
die Ukraine mehrere hundert
Marschflugkörper bereits verfeuert hat
und vielleicht noch im Jahr
Bereich von was nicht 100 bis 200
Marschflugkörper noch zur Verfügung
hätte und
die Frage ist wie lange dieser Vorrat
reichen wird und inwiefern man dadurch
eben sogenannte
sättigungs- oder übersättigungsangriffe
durchführen kann weil am effektivsten
sind diese marschflowkörper
einsetzbar oder einzusetzen eben indem
man sie nicht einzeln oder nur in einer
Gruppe von zwei oder drei am Abfall
schon wirklich Dutzende von
marshmallowkörpern eben auf ein Ziel
feiert es waren ja glaube ich auch
zehnmal Stücke Körper die die sehr
starke durfte was zu holen unter anderem
durchgeführt haben und ähm hier ist es
so dass man dadurch eben die
Flugabwehr die Raketen und Flugabwehr
auf russischer Seite dadurch übersättigt
das heißt es gibt zu viele Ziele am
Himmel und dadurch können auch einzelne
Raketen mit Sicherheit ihr Ziel treffen
das ist eben auch der Hauptgrund warum
es so dringend notwendig wäre im
zusätzliche Marschflugkörper an die
Ukraine zu schicken und hier ist der
Stichwort natürlich Taurus tausend Mal
für Körper aus Deutschland die
wahrscheinlich sehr dringend benötigt
würden
ja auf diese Taurus Debatte kommen wir
gleich noch mal zu sprechen ich habe
hier direkt mal eine Frage aus der
Community an sie hier fragt Michael
Müller auf youtube ist es nicht für die
Ukraine sowie für Russland eigentlich
unmöglich die Krim auf Dauer zu halten
das sehe ich nicht so also ehrlicher
ehrlich gesagt also ich glaube manche
Kommentatoren Kommentatorinnen
überschätzen mit wie wenig eigentlich
eine Streitkraft die in der Defensive
ist teilweise auskommen kann jetzt was
Munition betrifft was Nachschub und so
weiter betrifft
solange es möglich ist die Truppen auf
der Grillen gut zu versorgen und das
also zumindest minimal im mit Nachschub
zu versorgen das heißt also jetzt der
Munition und
Nahrungsmittel und so weiter Treibstoff
und die anderen Dinge er kann die
kriegen natürlich gehalten werden und
Sie dürfen nicht vergessen mehrere
Großmächte haben schon über die letzten
Jahrhunderte also um die kriegen
gekämpft also selbst wenn die Russen
abgeschnitten werden und sie trotzdem
verteidigen würde das kein Ärzte würde
das jetzt nicht ähm bedeuten dass diese
die dass die kriegen halt nicht so
sofort im fallen würde nur weil er
Nachschub abgeschrieben wird also wie
hier könnte es noch gröberen Kämpfen
kommen sollte sollte es wirklich zu
einer Invasion irgendwann einmal kommen
durch ukrainische Truppen
ja soweit erstmal zur Situation auf der
Krim lassen Sie uns mal von der
Halbinsel auf die Front im Süden gucken
da läuft aktuell weiterhin die auch hier
schon viel besprochene Gegenoffensive
der Ukraine an welchem Punkt befinden
sich die Ukraine mit dieser gegen
Offensive aktuell
nun auch das ist nicht so leicht am
Einschuss zu schätzen selbstverständlich
also ich glaube wir werden
einen kombinationspunkt in den kommenden
Wochen erreichen was meine ich mit einem
kombinationspunkt also dieses Jahr
Offensive wird ihren Höhepunkt erreichen
in den kommenden Wochen irgendwann im
Herbst ob das jetzt der Ende dieses
Monats ist oder Mitte nächstes Monat
Monats kann ich nicht abschätzen bzw
vielleicht geht's ja auch bis Ende
Oktober hier würde ich sagen ist nicht
das Wetter ausschlaggebend wie
vielleicht einige Kommentatoren und
Kommentatorinnen oft ähm
sagen sondern viel mehr glaube ich
geht's hauptsächlich hier um Reserven
weil die Reserven früher oder später
aufgebraucht sind und dann natürlich
auch der Munitionsverbrauch von beiden
Seiten aber eben vor allem auf
ukrainischer Seite also irgendwann
einmal wird es aus diesen zwei Gründen
wahrscheinlich so sein dass die
offensiven Tätigkeiten der griechischen
Streitkräfte sich abschwächen und ja in
dieser Hinsicht würde ich aber sagen wir
müssen jetzt nicht erwarten dass
irgendwann einmal die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ein Statement abliefern und
sagen okay die Offensive ist jetzt
vorbei es wird mit Sicherheit auch nach
diesem kombinationspunkt
weitergekämpft werden es werden auch
noch Gelände Gewinne sicher stattfinden
es wird auch der russische Gegner nach
wie vor abgenutzt werden und so weiter
also die Kampfhandlungen werden mit
Sicherheit weitergehen und es wird auch
so sein dass die Ukraine nach wie vor
selbst nach des Erreichens dieses
kombinationspunkt offensive Operationen
durchführen wird
sie sagen also dieser Höhepunkt dagegen
Offensive der steht uns eigentlich noch
bevor da frag ich mich direkt wir
berichten ja jetzt schon lange über die
gegen Offensive warum ist der Höhepunkt
dieser Offensive aus ihrer Sicht noch
nicht erreicht und was wird sich da ganz
konkret verändern also wie müssen wir
uns das vorstellen was kommt vielleicht
noch hinzu
also ich habe jetzt das grob
zusammengefasst also ein
kombinationspunkt auf militärisch
theoretischer Perspektive bedeutet
natürlich mehrere andere konkrete Dinge
die ich jetzt nicht im Detail auflisten
will ich glaube am besten übersetzt es
sich dennoch mit Höhepunkt der Offensive
das bedeutet aber nicht das plötzlich
jetzt dann noch zusätzliche Reserven im
großen Ausmaß reingeschmissen werden es
geht hier hauptsächlich darum dass das
jetzige operative Tempo also die
Operationen wie sie jetzt stattfinden
auch weiterhin in dem Tempo stattfinden
werden dass die Feuerrate sich
vielleicht leicht steigert bzw gleich
bleibt und ich meine damit eigentlich
dass mit kombinationspunkt eben
irgendwann einmal diese Feuerrate dieses
tempor an Operationen eben sich
reduzieren wird etwas und dann stärker
und langsam sich im abschwächtigt wenn
wir Richtung Winter gehen das meine ich
im Detail damit
jetzt gibt es in der letzten Zeit ja
auch Erfolgsmeldung für die Ukraine aus
der Nähe von bachmut zum Beispiel da
wurde ein Dorf befreit und es wird ja
auch gesagt dass nach dieser ersten
Verteidigungslinie wir haben es gerade
in der Karte gesehen da sind die
russischen verteidigungswelle in rot so
ein bisschen eingezeichnet das ist gar
nicht die Karte von der ich gerade
Sprache aber vielleicht habt ihr es
gerade gesehen da waren die
verteidigungswelle rot eingezeichnet man
sagt das nach dieser ersten
Verteidigungslinie gar nicht mehr so
viel kommt was glauben denn sie wie groß
ist denn die Chance in den kommenden
Wochen für einen Durchbruch der Ukraine
durch diese Welle
also ich glaube sie sagen es richtig im
Moment haben wir noch keinen Durchbruch
wir haben Einbrüche lokale Einbrüche an
diversen Stellen entlang der Frauen die
Ukraine selbstverständlich einige gute
Fortschritte gemacht dann in den letzten
Wochen aber es gab noch keinen
Durchbruch der wirklich am es ermöglicht
durch diese Lücke in den russischen
russischen Verteidigungslinien eben
mechanisierte Verbände das heißt
Kampfpanzer Schützenpanzer Artillerie
und so weiter durchzuschicken um eben
gegnerischen Raum in die Etappe im
vorzustoßen und das ist nach wie vor
selbstverständlich eines der Hauptziele
und ich glaube aber grundsätzlich
sollten wir uns nicht zu sehr auf diese
Verteidigungslinie auf diese
Stellungen im auf russischer Seite
konzentrieren diese
Verteidigungsstellungen waren immer
konzipiert eigentlich durchbrochen zu
werden früher oder später der Hauptpunkt
wo man diese Verteidigungslinien hat
diese Minenfelder und so weiter es geht
hier darum den ukrainischen Angriff
abzuschweichen bzw zu verlangsamen um
immer schnell Reserven auf russischer
Seite beizuführen um jeglichen Einbruch
quasi nicht zu ihm Durchbruch werden zu
lassen und hier muss es einfach den
Ukraine geringer gelingen schnell und
rapidee
durchzustoßen weil natürlich das andere
Problem ist sollte eine
Verteidigungslinie durchbrochen sein und
können die Russen wenn davor stoße auf
ukrainischer Seite nicht schnell genug
durchgeführt wird neue
Verteidigungslinien im aufziehen und das
ist eine normales Problem und das führt
natürlich auch dazu dass das operative
Tempo sich verlangsamt und sie dürfen
nicht für vergessen diese Angriffe auf
ukrainischer Seite aus mehreren Gründen
finden auf zugs- und Kompanie Ebene
statt also Einheiten zwischen 30 bis 200
Mann zu Fuß die im Schutz der Artillerie
die auf die russische Stellungen schießt
ein Vorgehen und aus diesem Grund sind
diese Angriffe auch langsamer als wenn
man mit Fahrzeugen fahren würde das
heißt weil die Munition nach vorne
gebracht werden muss zu Fuß die
Verwundeten müssen Abgrund transportiert
werden zu Fuß und das verlangsamt
natürlich das Tempo hier dieser dieser
Operation im allgemeinen es kann
natürlich aber noch zu größeren
Durchbrüchen in den kommenden Wochen
kommen also ich sage es gibt einen
Höhepunkt einen kombinationspunkt ich
kann Ihnen aber nicht sagen wie diese
Offensive ausgehen wird
da die vielen Dank erstmal bis hierhin
wir sehen uns gleich noch mal und
sprechen dann über weitere westliche
Unterstützung der Ukraine wie
analysieren auch noch mal was für
Herausforderungen vielleicht nach der
gegen Offensive auf die Ukraine warten
und ich werfe gerade mal einen Blick in
den Chat ich habe auch noch eine ganze
Menge Fragen aus der Community für Sie
von dieser Analyse der letzten Tage und
auch der ging Offensive blicken wir
jetzt darauf wie die Ukraine und Ukraine
sind eigentlich selbst auf diese
neuesten Entwicklungen schauen und dazu
schalten wir jetzt mal live nach
saporisha zu ZDF Reporter Henna
hebestreiter
guten Abend
wie werden denn diese Erfolge auf der
Krim der letzten Tage in der Ukraine
selbst wahrgenommen lenkt das den Fokus
so ein bisschen weg von der Front
ich sag mal auf Seiten der Ukrainerinnen
und Ukraine ist jede Nachricht eine gute
Nachricht die davon zeugt dass man den
Russen den russischen Kämpfern
ein Niederlage beigefügt hat oder einen
kleinen Erfolg in den Gefechten
beigefügt hat das war der von euch
vorhin erwähnte Sturm auf diese diese
Bohrinsel die man genommen hat und dann
sehr stolz auch eigenes Bildmaterial
dazu veröffentlicht hat das waren die
Attacken auf die Schiffe auf der auf der
Halbinsel Krim und heute morgen haben
sie auch noch ein Patienten Boot mit
einer Drohne beschossen also das sind
alles aus Sicht der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine die wir sprechen guten
Nachrichten auch wenn sie natürlich
wissen es ist ein sehr langer Krieg und
das was in den letzten Tagen passiert
ist ist ein minimaler Schritt in die aus
ihrer Perspektive richtige Richtung
jetzt wissen wir ja auch wie wichtig die
Krim für Putin ist strategisch wir haben
es gehört das ist ein
riesenlager für militärisches Gerät aber
eben auch symbolisch wie groß ist denn
aktuell die Angst in der Ukraine vor
einer Reaktion Putins also eventuell
einen Vergeltungsschlag
die ist erstaunlicherweise gering wir
haben heute morgen mit einer
Wissenschaftlerin gesprochen und haben
gesagt sag mal wie ist das denn habt ihr
nicht Angst haben sie nicht Angst dass
wenn Putin dort richtig unter Druck
gerät und er hat ja die die Krim und
sebastopolen mehrfach als eine rote
Linie bezeichnet wenn die Ukraine dort
zuschlagen würden würde er sich deutlich
wehren und da ist natürlich immer die
Sorge dass es dann doch mal zu zum
massiven Schlägen auf ukrainische
Einrichtungen kommen kann da hat er mir
gesagt nö die hat bislang immer nur
gedroht und deshalb nichts bewirkt und
das wird auch jetzt wiederum so sein ist
deren Haltung die wir sehr häufig hören
und auch wir hatten als wir Anfang der
Woche in Kiel fahren uns überlegt jetzt
sind wir hier und wird sich der wird
sich die russische Seite sehr symbolisch
wären oder
da einen Signal setzen wollen und es ist
nichts passiert ich kann das von hier
nicht beurteilen ob da noch irgendein
etwas in der Hinterhand steckt aber um
es gerade ich weiß nicht ob sie das hier
hören aber hier wird eine große Hochzeit
gefeiert und das macht man ja nicht wenn
man der Meinung ist man ist jetzt voller
Angst und Sorge dass da was passieren
kann
ja ein Stück Normalität im Kriegsalltag
jetzt ist es ja so das nächste Woche
ziemlich wichtige treffen anstehen
Treffen der Ukraine Kontaktgruppe in
Ramstein wir haben die unvollversammlung
in New York was wird da denn von Seiten
der Ukraine erwartet
naja ich meine der viel beschriebene
elefante immer im Raum steht sind die
Taurus Marschflugkörper darum ging es ja
auch Anfang der Woche beim Besuch der
bundesaußenministerin in Kiew wo ist ein
ziemliches Blut gegeben hat mit der
ukrainischen Seite
da wird es sicherlich noch mal darum
gehen ob Deutschland und jetzt diese
Taurus Marschflugkörper liefern kann es
geht sicherlich auch um Flugzeuge
das war sehr interessant zu beobachten
in hiesigen Medien heute Nachmittag da
hat man wohl den
Bundesverteidigungsminister etwas
missverstanden auf einmal war die
Nachricht im Umlauf des hieß innerhalb
von 1 bis 2 Wochen würde Deutschland
über Taurus entscheiden da musste die
Bundesregierung ganz schnell vor die
Presse treten und sagen nein an der
Haltung der Bundesregierung habe sich
nichts geändert mein persönlicher
Eindruck ist an dem ich die
bundesaußenministerin hier in Kiel
erlebt hat dass sie da ein absehbarer
Zeit auch nichts bewegen wird es würde
mich selbst sehr überraschen wenn es bei
den Gesprächen in Rammstein tatsächlich
in der Richtung eine Bewegung geben wird
ja wir sind gespannt was passiert danke
Hannah für deine Einblick von vor Ort
und alles Gute in die Ukraine
danke schön
ja und über diese mögliche Unterstützung
der Ukraine aus Deutschland mit Taurus
marschlu-körpern und dem generellen
Ausblick auch über die Gegenoffensive
hinaus darüber spreche ich jetzt noch
mal mit militäranalyst Franz Stefan Gady
der uns wieder zugeschaltet ist guten
abend noch mal
guten Abend jetzt ist es ja so diese
Taurus Lieferung keiner in Deutschland
aus der Bundesregierung hat aktuell viel
Lust darüber zu sprechen der
Bundeskanzler lässt über seine
Regierungssprecher ausrichten die
Prüfung laufen noch Frau bärbox sagt sie
habe dazu eigentlich alles gesagt und
Boris pistorisch eigentlich auch nicht
mehr so richtig was sagen jetzt hat das
ist ja auch ein Stück weit bekannt es
gibt große Sorgen durch unter anderem
die gewaltige Reichweite dieser Waffen
wir können uns das hier auch mal
angucken hier gibt es nämlich in der ZDF
heute App ein ziemlich eine ziemlich
allumfassende Erklärung der Taurus
Marshmallow Körper das könnt ihr euch
nachher mal in der App angucken und da
steht unter anderem dass dieser Taurus
autark bis zu 500 km im tieflug
zurücklegen kann 500 km das ist ganz
schön viel und das ist auch eine Sorge
in Deutschland gerade weil man sich
fragt mit diesen Körpern könnte man ja
auch bis nach russ fliegen und dort
Ziele angreifen und noch zu dem sind
diese marschflowkörper sehr effektiv
sehr durchschlagend also
Herr gardi wie ist das denn jetzt in
Deutschland wenn wie ist das denn wenn
Deutschland sich jetzt entscheiden würde
zu liefern wie schnell wären denn solche
komplexen Geräte solche sehr effizienten
aber sehr komplexen Geräte wie schnell
wären die einsetzbar für die Ukraine
wissen was der Zustand dieser einzelnen
Systeme im Arsenal der Bundeswehr ist da
wie viele wirklich zur Verfügung werden
wie schnell die dann auch wirklich
geliefert werden können es bedarf
natürlich dann auch einer Schulung an
personalausbildung und so weiter und
dann wahrscheinlich auch Unterstützung
in irgendeiner Weise die aber jetzt
wirklich von Deutschland aus erledigt
werden könnte es müssen jetzt da keine
deutschen Techniker oder Soldaten in die
Ukraine um hier
irgendeine Unterstützung eben zu leisten
da zweite Punkt eben diese Reichweite
also diese Debatte ist jetzt was er
jegliche eskalationsdynamiken betreffen
dieser Virus Russland komplett fehl am
Platz meiner Meinung nach weil durch die
Reichweite eines System entstehen ja
keine großen
eskalationsdynamiken hier oder Risiken
in dieser Hinsicht wenn man bedenkt was
in den letzten eineinhalb Jahren für
verschiedene Systeme aus dem Westen in
der Ukraine zum Einsatz gekommen sind
und
man darf nicht vergessen vor allem dass
Storm Shadow und französische
Marschflugkörper also Storm Shadow ist
ein britisches Produkt eben schon seit
einigen Monaten im Einsatz ist in der
Ukraine die haben ungefähr eine
Reichweite ja bis 300 Kilometer ein
bisschen darüber ein bisschen weniger je
nachdem eben wie sie abgefeuert werden
und ich glaube nicht dass es hier dann
plötzlich eine rote Linie gibt wenn man
davon spricht das vielleicht ein Arsch
verkörper 500 km hat die Ukraine hat
sich bis jetzt strikt daran gehalten
nicht ähm russisches Territorium mit
diesen Marschflugkörpern zu bekämpfen
als ich sehe hier kein Problem in der
Hinsicht und man kann natürlich auch am
technische Lösungen am präsentieren wie
man zum Beispiel auch auf dich aus auf
technischer Ebene garantieren kann eben
das diese Maß für Körper nicht gegen
russische Ziele eingesetzt werden also
jetzt da über die Grenze hinaus
russische Ziele treffen können in dieser
Hinsicht sehe ich eigentlich keine
Bedenken was irgendwelche
eskalationsrisiken betrifft und diese
Waffen werden sehr dringend benötigt
diese Waffensysteme werden gebraucht von
der Ukraine und ich glaube Sie sollten
aus diesem Grund auch schnellstmöglich
geliefert werden
was sie da gerade ansprechen das ist
ganz interessant es wird gerade
diskutiert inwiefern man eigentlich wenn
jetzt Deutschland solche Geräte liefern
würde inwiefern deutsche Soldaten
deutsche Arbeiter im Prinzip assistieren
müssten um die Koordinaten einzugeben in
diese Geräte das ist nämlich ein äußerst
komplexer Vorgang und es könnte sein
dass eine Sorge der Bundesregierung
aktuell ist wenn deutsche Soldaten dort
assistieren würden wäre würde das
Deutschland schon zu einer Kriegspartei
machen wie stehen Sie dazu sie sagen ja
das ist eigentlich gar nicht notwendig
ja also ich kann das mit einem Wort
jetzt zu sagen nein Deutschland wird
keine Kriegspartei sein und ich glaube
das muss man auch nicht ausdiskutieren
das kann auch sehr gut nachlesen
nein also dieses Problem sehe ich nicht
was was jetzt da den Einsatz dieser
Waffensysteme betrifft dann wäre ja
Deutschland auch Kriegspartei weil es
den geparkt geliefert hat dann wäre
Deutschland kriegsbeteil weil es an
andere Waffensysteme schon geliefert hat
Leopard 2 wir gehen immer wieder durch
die gleiche Debatte im deutschsprachigen
Europa was diese Waffensysteme diese
einzelnen Waffensysteme betrifft und ich
glaube es werden Zeit einfach nicht so
sehr auf einzelne Waffensysteme zu
blicken sondern einfach eine
Gesamtstrategie zu entwickeln wie wir
gut die Ukraine unterstützen können weil
jetzt die Entscheidungen die wir jetzt
treffen werden schlagend werden im Jahr
2024 wenn wir eine Lektion Mitnehmen von
dieser jetztigen Offensive ist dass wir
als westliche Partner der Ukraine viel
zu spät damit begonnen haben Munition zu
liefern Waffensysteme zu liefern
systematisch ukrainische Truppen
auszubilden wir müssen jetzt da schon
die Arbeit erledigen die
Rahmenbedingungen setzen um die Ukraine
auch in zukünftigen offensiven 2024
unterstützen zu können und hier sollte
wirklich nicht gezögert werden aber ist
das nicht ich muss jetzt noch mal
nachfragen ist das nicht ein
qualitativer Unterschied wir haben
natürlich auch bei den Leopard-Panzern
und anderen Gerät darüber gesprochen
jetzt ist ja bei hier diese Frage ob
tatsächlich deutsche Soldaten in die
Ukraine müssten um dort bei diesem Gerät
zu assistieren das ist ja schon ein
Unterschied oder
ja wie gesagt ich ich sehe den Grund
nicht also vielleicht gibt es einen zu
sehr eine Zuseherin die mehr vertraut
ist mit dem Waffensystem und
widerspricht mehr aber ich jetzt von
meinem Verständnis was diesen
marschallkörper betrifft bedarf es
keiner deutschen Präsenz in der Ukraine
um diese Waffen in irgendeiner Weise
einsatzbereit zu machen
diese Debatte geht halt schon eine Weile
wir haben auch gerade aus der Ukraine
gehört da gab es jetzt fälschlicherweise
die Meldung das Berufs Pistorius sich in
den nächsten zwei Wochen dazu
entscheiden werde wenn wir jetzt mal
einen Blick in die Zukunft werfen wenn
Deutschland sich entscheiden sollte
überhaupt zu liefern was prognostizieren
sie wie viel wird das sein in welchem
Umfang und wann wäre das überhaupt
möglich
ja ich meine das sind alles jetzt da ich
kann Ihnen jetzt keine keinen Zeitrahmen
in Wirklichkeit geben das hängt von sehr
vielen Bedingungen ab ich kann ihnen
auch keine Anzahl hier nennen das kann
ich nicht im Detail machen ich könnte
jetzt der Schätzungen angeben
irgendetwas von 100 bis vielleicht 300
Maßstabe die Deutschland möglicherweise
in den kommenden Monaten liefern könnte
aber ich glaube man darf auch nicht
verstehen vergessen hier in diese
debatterien von einem einzelnen
Waffensystem dieses einzelne
Waffensystem wird nicht Kriegs
entscheidend sein es geht hier wirklich
nur darum die eine Fähigkeit die bereits
in der ukrainischen Streitkräften
vorhanden ist zur weiteren es gibt ja
schon Sturm Shadow Marschflugkörper und
andere Körper aus westlichen Beständen
hier geht es einfach darum in dieser
abnutzungsstrategie die die Ukraine wie
so wie Russland fährt eben die
russischen Streitkräfte auch weiterhin
unter Druck zu halten also den Druck
aufrecht zu halten und wenn man zum
Beispiel 200 unserem Körper liefert dann
müsste man auch wirklich sagen das
könnte die Ukraine vielleicht für ein
paar Monate eben genügen aber es muss
nachgeliefert werden also die
Dimensionen von der Quantität ja was
Munition im betrifft und anderen
Nachschub übersteigen wirklich allen
unseren Erwartungen wahrscheinlich oder
zumindest nicht jetzt uns
militäranalysten aber vielleicht für die
allgemeine Öffentlichkeit also wir reden
ja nicht von hunderten Systemen die
notwendig werden sondern wirklich
tausenden von Systemen die in so einem
abnutzungskrieg traurigerweise gebraucht
werden
lassen Sie uns jetzt mal so ein bisschen
den Blick über den tellerrandwagen Weg
von der gegen Offensive fragt nämlich
gerade auch schon einen User auf Youtube
was Leute Ukraine gehen Winter wenn sie
es nicht bis nach militour schafft
eingraben wie es also das Szenario wenn
die Offensive durch den Winter gestoppt
wird es gibt ja jetzt einige Stimmen es
bleiben die sagen das eigentlich nur
noch 30 bis 40 Tage bleiben ist das
Wetter wieder sehr schlecht wird
wie gesagt ich sage das Wetter ist ein
secondarrer Grund warum diese Offensive
vielleicht in den kommenden Wochen
schwächer wird ich glaube nicht dass es
das Wetter ausschlaggebend oder
entscheidende Faktor sein werde ich
glaube eben es geht hauptsächlich um
Reserven mangeln mangelnde
Munitionsvorräte das möchte ich noch
einmal hier unterstreichen nun ich
glaube die Angriffe werden weitergehen
und wenn ich mit ukrainischen Soldaten
Offizieren und so weiter rede dann ist
schon die Rede das Talk macht z.B also
Talk Marketing strategisch wichtiger
Verkehrsknotenpunkt eine Stadt eben im
Süden also in saborischer eben die von
den Russen besetzt sind die eine Stadt
die zur Festung ausgebaut wurde dass das
nach wie vor ein Ziel ist und dieses
Ziel wird auch nicht aus den Augen
gelassen und hier wird wahrscheinlich
die ukraineische der ukrainische
Schwerpunkt fortgesetzt werden Ihnen
also kommenden Wochen und und Monaten
und ich glaube der Druck hier wird nicht
jetzt da komplett verschwinden für
russische Frontlinie an dieser an dieser
Stelle also ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass wir vielleicht dennoch auch wenn
eben diese Offensive abgeschwächt
stattfindet irgendwann einmal doch ein
Einbruch vielleicht sogar ein Durchbruch
gelingt und man zumindest bis auf die
Höhe von talkmack vorstoßen kann man
muss die Stadt ja nicht wirklich
einnehmen man kann die Stadt auch um
singen bzw flankieren und weiter
vorstoßen und so weiter einkesseln aber
ja ich glaube das offensive Operationen
dennoch stattfinden werden und man darf
auch jetzt nicht außer Acht lassen das
selbstverständlich auch die russischen
Streitkräfte in anderen Teilen der
Frauen also ich sage jetzt in der Gegend
um kopieranz geben offensiv tätig werden
bzw hier versuchen ukrainische
Streitkräfte zu binden also ich würde es
auch nicht ausschließen dass es hier
auch auf russischer Seite in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten stärkere
offensiven offensive Aktionen im
durchgeführt werden
dieser Knotenpunkt das ist ein wichtiger
Punkt das sieht man auch ganz gut an den
verteidigungsfällen die sich darum
bewegen eingezeichnet in der Karte und
dazu fragt Tom Kaiser auf Youtube wie
weit muss der Korridor auf sein um bis
nach tokmark zu kommen was ist auf
diesem Weg noch wichtig
es muss breit genug sein dass an
einerseits russische
panzerabwehrlenkwaffen nicht mehr
flankierend wirken können das heißt also
wenn mechanisierte Kräfte durchstoßen
dass eben diese Flanken wirklich sicher
sind ja das hängt natürlich vom Terran
ab das hängt von der Topographie eben
das Geländes im Detail ab das müsste man
sich dann wirklich in einer Lage
beurteilen bei Beurteilung direkt vor
Ort auch ansehen als Kommandant eben das
kann ich jetzt dann nicht natürlich von
ein paar 100 km Entfernung im Detail
beurteilen dann bedarf es
selbstverständlich auch Flugabwehr die
eben vor allem Helikoptern und
russischen Drohnen im schützen muss also
vor allem also Kamikaze Drohnen und so
weiter um diesen mechanisierten
Durchbruch eben zu ermöglichen natürlich
muss auch die Infanterie hier ihre ihre
ihre Gutes tun das heißt also wirklich
auch diese mechanisierten Verbände auf
der Flanke schützen und ja ich kann
keinen Zeitrahmen geben wie gesagt es
kann ein Durchbruch noch stattfinden es
hängt wirklich davon ab wie die
Situation auf beiden Seiten ist und
diese Offensive steht und fällt in
Wirklichkeit mit a Munitionsverbrauch
und B Reserven wenn eine der beiden
Seiten in den kommenden Wochen größere
Schwächen in diesen beiden Kategorien
zeigt dann könnte sich natürlich das
Krieg noch am wenden
ja Thema Reserven Thema militärische
Ausstattung auch was was die User
interessiert hier fragt noch jemand auf
Youtube sollte die Ukraine ohne F16
nicht besser die Offensive pausieren
jetzt haben sie Panzer aber keine
Luftwaffe im Frühjahr haben Sie
vielleicht eine F16 Luftwaffe aber keine
Panzer
nein also ich glaube die Ukraine wird
nach wie vor genügend Panzer haben vor
allem eben wie gesagt es ist
hauptsächlich hier ein infantrieb haben
für Moment also mechanisierte Verbände
schützen sonst der Kampfpanzer kommen
nur sehr punktuell zum Einsatz während
einzeln eingesetzt oder zu zweit
eingesetzt teilweise zu fahren
Unterstützung die Verluste für eine
derartige ebenso weit wir das beurteilen
können eben was Kampfpanzern betrifft
sind relativ
minimalistischer Seite und
selbstverständlich würde es helfen das
F6 16
Kampfjet so einen so eine offensiv in
Zukunft unterstützen ich glaube aber es
würde auch ohne die F16 Kampfjets gehen
bzw würde die Ausbildung wahrscheinlich
länger dauern ist viele denken es ist
das eine F 16 zu fliegen es ist das
andere f16m wirklich im Kampf der
verbundenen Waffen also gut integriert
in dieser Offensive im einzusetzen und
das könnte ja längere Zeit ja
also ein längeren Zeitrahmen eben
beanspruchen der wahrscheinlich die in
diesem Zeitrahmen hat die Ukraine glaube
ich nicht eben um hier nicht in Zukunft
also 2024 nicht noch vielleicht ohne
derartige Kampfflugzeuge erneut das
versuchen zu müssen oder zumindest im
kleineren Rahmen eben offensive
Operationen durchzuführen also ich würde
jetzt nicht eine Debatte wieder führen
was gebraucht wird oder auf das nächste
Waffensystem setzen wir müssen wirklich
von dieser Ebene Weg wo wir zu sehr
fokussiert sind auf einzelne
Waffensysteme zu und viel mehr denken im
Kampf der verbundenen Waffen wie man
diese Systeme gut integriert und vor
allem wie man alles Mögliche dafür tun
kann die ukrainischen Streitkräfte gut
zu trainieren sie gut auszubilden eben
die Moral hochzuhalten also aufrecht zu
erhalten und alle anderen Faktoren die
wichtig sind ein Krieg steht und fällt
bzw kriegst Glück wird nicht entschieden
durch einzelne Waffensysteme also ich
möchte das wirklich jetzt immer auch
dass diese öffentliche Debatte
vielleicht auf andere Teile fokussiert
und wir haben hier noch eine Frage zu
den verteidigungswellen die wir wie
gesagt gerade in der Karte gesehen haben
wird es den Russen erneut möglich sein
ihre verteidigungsstellen derart stark
auszubauen wie es ihnen bei äh bis zur
diesjährigen Offensive gelungen ist wie
könnten die Ukraine dieses mal sowas
verhindern
nun die stärkste Verteidigungslinie und
das wissen wir jetzt erst in der
Retrospektive war die erste
Verteidigungslinie die die Ukraine
durchbrochen hat
es ist alles relativ also die
Verteidigungslinie ist die stärkste die
im die russische Seite vorzieht zu
verteidigen das heißt also wir könnten
natürlich noch auf relativ starke
Verteidigungsstellungen
stoßen das heißt wir jetzt wenn ich mich
jetzt der also wenn ich die Seite Sache
aus ukrainischer Perspektive mehr ansehe
ich glaube das große Problem hier ist
für die ukrainische Streitkräfte im von
diesen Kram Krieg von diesem
abnutzungskrieg in einem Bewegungskrieg
überzugehen das heißt wenn man Krieg
woah mechanisiert werden die
Kriegsführung wo mich interessierte
Verbände rapide eben im Hinterland
vorstoßen russische Verbände einkesseln
bzw
die Nachschubwege für die russischen
Truppen an der Frauen im abschneiden und
so weiter und in dieser Hinsicht wäre
das dass ideal selbstverständlich nur
ist es enorm schwierig wenn es eben vor
allem eben diese luftparität gibt keine
der beiden Seiten hat also kontrolliert
wirklich den Luftraum das ist natürlich
ein Faktor herum auch unter anderem
diese Vorstöße sehr brenzlig ausgehen
könnten auch ja wenn nicht genug
Flugabwehr
und Raketenabwehr und so weiter auch
vorgeschoben wird mit diesen Angriffen
hier geht es natürlich wieder um den
Kampf der verbundenen Waffen aber ja
selbstverständlich können die Russen neu
Verteidigungslinien aufziehen und hier
geht es vor allem eben um die
Geschwindigkeit also wirklich das
operative Tempo hier ist hier
entscheiden wie schnell kann
durchgebrochen werden wie schnell können
diese Durchbrüche erweitert werden und
wie schnell können eben
nachstehende Verbände
nachgeschoben werden bzw können auch
Reserven dann zum Einsatz gebracht
werden und wiederum hängt das vor allem
von den Reserven ab wenn er Durchbruch
entsteht was für Reserven habe ich in
diesem Buch auszuweiten
ja und um diesen Ausblick sollte es zu
einem Durchbruch kommen darum dreht sich
auch die letzte Frage man hat zuletzt
gehört dass die Ukraine weitere Männer
einziehen muss wie viel Manpower
Potential hat das Land noch bzw wie hoch
schätzen Sie die Durchhaltefähigkeit des
Landes ein
also der Kampf ist Wille ist ungebrochen
und nach mehreren Besuchen auch in der
Ukraine und nach einiger Zeit ich in
diesem Land jetzt auch in den letzten
zwölf Monaten alleine verbracht habe
glaube ich nicht dass dieser Kampf ist
Wille in naher Zukunft in irgendeiner
Weise geschwächt werden wird oder
brechen wird natürlich gibt es
Abnutzungserscheinungen und ich sehe das
immer wieder auch wenn ich Soldaten
treffe die ich vor drei Monaten das
letzte Mal gesehen habe man sieht den
Krieg in den Augen der Menschen einfach
also das Land wird noch viele Jahre
damit zu kämpfen haben und es ist
einfach eine schreckliche schreckliche
Sache und wissen Sie ich als
militäranalyst Rede natürlicher jetzt
darüber Taktik Strategie und ja
Reichweite von marschflughörnern und so
weiter mit auf nie vergessen ihm was
dahinter steht und was diese einzelnen
Waffensysteme führen zerstörerisches
Potential haben und ähm was die auch
anrichten und was für schreckliche Dinge
hier wirklich auch täglich täglich
täglich passieren und ähm ich will damit
sagen eben der Kampf ist wieder
ist noch da wird auch jetzt dann
keinster Weise glaube ich am brechen
aber natürlich ist es so dass dieser
Krieg große Opfer von der Ukraine
fordert und in dieser Hinsicht glaube
ich auch verdient die Ukraine unsere
Unterstützung und hier wird natürlich
auch unser westliches System verteidigt
einfach das auch die Idee dass ein
souveräner Staat eben nicht einfach
Opfer eines aggresses wird also ich
glaube schon im dass langfristig dieser
Konflikt ja sehr entscheidend sein wird
für die europäische Sicherheit der
Architektur und deshalb bedarf ist auch
unser vollen Unterstützung meiner
Meinung nach
ja mal gucken was bei den schon
angesprochenen treffen nächste Woche
herauskommt Herr die vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns waren meine Fragen
beantwortet haben die Fragen mehr
Community beantwortet haben schönen
Abend noch
danke schön
ja euch bewegt dieses Thema nach wie vor
sehr ihr habt jede Menge Fragen und
Kommentare geschrieben hier schreibt
jemand auf Youtube ein Nein zu Taurus
kann sich ein Verteidigungsminister
nicht leisten und Markus schreibt
natürlich kann die Ukraine gewinnen
alles eine Frage von Definition und
Unterstützung des Westens also wieder
selbst das Thema beziehungsweise
russischer Wirtschaft ja wie ist mit der
Offensive weitergeht ob sie in die
nächste Phase geht ob sie absprechen
wird ob sie zu einem Höhepunkt kommen
wird wie wir es gerade von Herrn gar die
gehört haben ihr werdet hier bei ZDF
heute live erfahren danke für eure
Fragen und Kommentare und bis zum
nächsten Mal